what's going on guys welcome to part 10
of our machine learning with
scikit-learn and Python and a whole
bunch of other things actually anyway
what were we doing - this video is
actually labeling our data so like I was
saying and you've probably seen now the
most intensive part of machine learning
is just getting the data and structuring
the data normalizing the data which we
still have yet to do because we only
have one feature so we don't really need
to normalize it too much but all of
those things just take up so much time
and now what we're gonna do is go ahead
and label this data and this labeling
will will ring true no matter how many
features we have the first thing I want
to go ahead and show is you know
performance-wise kind of an interesting
concept really that I find is you know
can we prove or disprove the idea of
momentum investing even and so a lot of
people support momentum investing and
investing and historically I haven't but
my findings here are actually quite
interesting so anyways let's go ahead
and get started
so we're gonna we've got difference and
then now we're gonna add one new thing
to our data frame and that's going to be
status and at every step of the way
we're going to ask what is the status is
it outperform our underperform compared
to the starting value so so we've got
status here and eventually what we could
do is we could store the previous value
and then we could say from you know the
last data point we had did they perform
wrap underperform wrapper form and all
this and then you'll see in a little bit
here we're going to have a kind of
another dichotomy that will happen and
that's you know should we consider at
every step of the way our performing
your performing or like just in general
where did they end up so more a lot more
on that later
but so for now we've got status okay mmm
and now what we do is we're going to
come down to where we were calculating
percentage change which is
here and let's add a couple more
variables first of all we're gonna we're
gonna go ahead and just define
difference so difference where we kind
of hot
hard to coded it so we're gonna do that
and then we'll just call this difference
here difference and then we'll come over
here difference equals that and then
we're also going to do the following
we're gonna say if difference is greater
than zero this means our status is out
excess needs to be quotes outperform and
then else status equals under perform
okay so again difference is just the
percentage change for the stock -
percentage change - the sp500 if that's
greater than zero it means it has
outperformed if it's less than zero it
means that is underperformed so now
we're gonna add one more down here now
and we do status and status is
equivalent to status easy enough now
we're gonna come down to where we're
graphing this stuff and basically we
really need to add that legend price
last that's kind of inefficient but
anyways within this try and except here
we're just gonna do the following so
before we actually plot it basically
right here we're going to ask the
following question we're gonna say if
plot on our score DF status and then
we're gonna ask that the negative first
if element which means the last element
if that equals under underperform let's
learn the type here we're gonna say
color equals R for red else color equals
G for green we plot we're saying label
equals each ticker and then we're going
to go ahead and comma and we're gonna
say color equals
color easy enough so we'll plot it and
again this will be applying the lines
based on the final value it's quite
difficult well actually I mean it's a
little more difficult to change the
lines color like mid line it is possible
to do and maybe I'll show that down the
road but for now we're not gonna deal
with that and let's just let's just look
real quickly and add a stock no way dude
okay so so we get this you know large
plot here and we can see okay there's
Apple just doing its thing outperforming
like crazy let's go ahead and just zoom
in and kind of ignore Apple for now and
so here we can kind of see that you know
once out once an out performer almost
always an out performer but some of
these companies did kind of underperform
for a little bit and then as time went
on they moved on to outperform and then
some of these just right at the last
second outperform but we can't see some
of the companies that initially strongly
outperformed died died back down and
that was probably people who maybe over
leveraged stuff like that anyway but for
the most part I mean just looking at
this we can kind of see that for the
most part out performers outperform and
underperformers underperform but later
on we will we're going to do both most
likely because I'm very curious to see
which is the superior method but we will
for at first we'll just start with their
ending value right there actually hmm
really sure I think what wound up doing
both I'm not really sure how I'm gonna
start it off either
but with underperforming overperform
basically we've now labeled this company
as either a buy or I sell and so we've
got our label and that can be translated
as a 0 or a 1 and so now our table data
is labeled and we need to learn how we
can now take this data and we can do
machine learning on this data and so
we're gonna save that now for the next
video but in the next video we'll
actually
I believe be covering actual you know
machine learning in an actual example so
anyways very exciting stay tuned for
that
I realize we actually already did cover
a machine learning example but now with
the knowledge you have you have your own
data the previous machine learning
example you didn't have your own data so
it's a little harder there's a bit of a
disconnect there as far as what all the
data you know parts are so in this next
video you'll at least see linear SVC and
an example of how to do that so anyways
stay tuned for that if you have any
questions or comments on this video
please do feel free to leave them below
otherwise as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support of the
subscriptions until next time
you